long months of economy crushing
lockdowns americans will finally get
another coveted relief check in the mail
congress reaching an agreement on a 900
billion dollar stimulus package
that includes a direct payment of 600
dollars to most americans
and now political leaders once again
proving its politics over the people
while nancy and company dragged their
feet on delivering much needed relief to
out-of-work americans
they wasted no time in jumping to the
front of the line to get the coronavirus
vaccine ahead
of healthcare workers and our seniors
here's a healthy
31 year old aoc getting her shot this
weekend
the covent vaccine became available to
members of congress last night
and we are urged to take it okay
that's it new hampshire governor chris
sununu is blasting lawmakers for their
selfishness
tweeting congress has literally done
nothing these last
eight months now they're cutting the
line and getting the vaccine ahead of
residents in long-term care
nurses and essential workers who stock
our shelves
it's outrageous and insulting and even
fellow squad member ilan omar
raising the issue tweeting
it's now clear that we don't have enough
vaccines for everyone and there is
shortage of supply we have to prioritize
those who need it most
that's why it's disturbing to see
members to be first to get vaccine
while most front line workers elderly
and infirm in our districts
wait meanwhile joe biden doing a vaccine
180
getting his shot this afternoon after
spending months publicly undermining it
during the lead up to the election all
right there's a lot of talk about here
greg gutfeld
i mean 600. doesn't seem like it's that
much considering what this country's
gone through and
how do you feel about someone like aoc
going to the front of the line
well there's two stories here there's
one story that really isn't that
important
and then there's a huge story what's not
important right now
is the argument about the politicians
going first because
the argument that they have to instill
confidence makes sense to me because if
they didn't go first
the message would be that they don't
trust the vaccine so aoc's argument
was that if i'm asking you to do it i'll
do it too
um and if you're nervous i'll go first
seems to me
to make sense because if you can lose on
both sides
then it's not an argument like if you
don't take it first you lose
if you take it first you lose then it's
not an argument the hypocrisy is when a
person
rags on a republican like marco rubio
and then applauds
joe biden then you're a hack so you have
to be consistent
but the bigger the bigger problem and
it's one that's so huge it's it's
disgusting
is how many months have passed from the
last stimulus which is like four to six
months okay
so that means these jerks in dc didn't
change their behavior at all given the
threat
they didn't let the fact that millions
were suffering affect their political
uh machinations uh it was just like old
times to them
it was just like if you if any old bill
now you compare that to say trump and
the vaccine where he changed
the industry paradigm so what took four
years took seven months
but the fact that they chose not to act
as if it's an emergency
they should have acted like this is an
emergency the same way trump did with
the vaccines
the fact that they chose not to act like
it was an emergency
for political reasons is like the
biggest
story of this year that they just sat
back and folded their hands while people
were suffering
that's the story yeah and geraldo it's
not even going to get out to people
before christmas
when they need to buy presents when they
need to pay bills
you know it should have come a lot
sooner and now
six hundred dollars i mean that's like
one or two bills to a lot of people
it should have been sooner it should
have been bigger but jesse as far as i
know congress has not yet
formally approved this thing and then
it's got to go to the president's desk i
hope it happens
sometimes tonight it was supposed to
happen yesterday you know what uh what
really irks me though is i watch aoc get
the shot even though
she's 46 younger 46 years younger than i
am i'm not bitter
is how they bad mouth this vaccine how
they
they they would not take it if trump's
name was attached to it and
uh you know uh they they raised all
these problems that they are now
purporting to solve by heroically
getting the shot that they've been
slandering all this time i will say that
the president-elect joe biden was
extremely gracious
after getting his shot today he did
credit
operation wharf speed and the trump
administration for their
efforts he didn't i didn't go overboard
he didn't call heroic as i do
it was heroic but at least he showed an
aspect of grace and recognition of his
predecessor's
success in doing something unprecedented
something extraordinary getting
this this vaccine created within a year
jesse and i thought he was very brave to
show those hairy skinny arms
on national television dana perino
and just to be fair i mean aoc didn't
flinch didn't look away when she got the
shot i saw rubio
like wincing and looking the other
direction
and that's not not and teasing anybody
but what you spoke to mitch mcconnell
earlier today
what was his reaction he wasn't very
happy because it looked like this was
pretty much the same deal as they had
ready to go in the summer
yeah first of all um you were doing so
well on your
new year's resolution denigrate
anybody's personal appearance
wait have we done the new year's
resolution announcements yet
in the future you will yeah okay
i i'll i'll comment on aoc's um
ability to like take that shot and and
not flinch
one of the things i've noticed is like
for me
i can watch the shots no problem i don't
flinch
it doesn't bother me when we showed all
those videos from early on
of the test with the long one that goes
all the way up into your brain
i had to look away every time that was
on the screen
because it really that one made me
flinch so i think
to greg's point we have to get people
comfortable
that the vaccine is safe and it's going
to help us
it'll help us stay healthier it will
help us get the economy back
in order and help these businesses
reopen the restaurants reopen
if you want to get back to normal this
is the path forward
i do think that mitch mcconnell was very
frustrated this deal that they signed
today is pretty much the one they had in
june
which would have provided money for
schools vaccine distribution all of the
things that they said they wanted but
they held on to
not only that jessie but speaker pelosi
even turned down steve mnuchin's
1.8 trillion dollar offer because that
wasn't big enough
and that was one that president trump
might have even signed so
i again i go back to my list of her
having a pretty bad year i do think that
this 600 dollars feels like much too
little too late i read a lot about the
upcoming evictions
that people are facing right now and
police officers who are having to go to
homes and knock on the door and to tell
them they're going to have to leave and
it is painful for everybody it is not
their fault that they can't work
this should have been done a long time
ago and i hope that people remember who
held this up
yeah and uh katie if you're afraid of
needles or squeamish about it don't
watch cable for the next couple months
because that's all you're gonna see
is b-roll of people getting stuck with
the needle but i do agree with greg i
don't see a problem with politicians
getting shots
i think they're just trying to lead by
example and um
you know there's nothing wrong with that
well i'm over here doing slow breathing
exercises so i don't pass out
on national television watching all
these people get the shot
talking about the shot it's really hard
for me to do this but i'm gonna
i'm going to make it through um on the
bill i'm very happy
that congress has gotten through real
aid for businesses
gig workers small businesses etc because
it's compensation for the government
shutting them down and telling them they
can't work they took away their
livelihood they are owed compensation
what i don't like about this bill and uh
senator rand paul talked about this on
the floor of the senate today
is that there are hundreds of millions
of dollars for
foreign countries for projects that are
unrelated to covet relief
and so while americans are getting a
check for 600
we're sending hundreds of millions of
dollars to foreign countries so
it's again just very frustrating to
watch washington push through a 5 000
page bill that none of them have really
read by the way
um full of stuff that is irrelevant to
the actual issue um so you know nothing
to do about it now but we are
really in debt and as around paul
pointed out six trillion dollars we
spent last year
or this year we only brought in three
trillion and somebody is going to have
to pay for that eventually
well i'm going to have my assistant
johnny in the commercial break read all
5 000
pages of the bill and find all the pork
and we'll report
what we find